and congrats on your 25th anniversary
that's incredible and I I
saw a video like I feel like Courtney
has another job that he could do like
party planning should be his event
planning should be his that was quite
the party it was quite the Extravaganza
I don't even know if I've been to a
party like that I know I hadn't I was
like it was an event what you walk into
a chandeliers gracing I was like whoop
and then y'all were dancing you are so
sexy I was just like whatever I was like
it was it was such a big surprise he
planned all that I was out of I was out
of the country working during the summer
and then I I came back and I happened to
be walking in the backyard and it was
torn up dirt everywhere it was just
Mayhem it was crazy wow and I was like
that's a very nice word
yeah he was like you weren't supposed to
go but I wasn't supposed to go in the no
one told me I wasn't supposed to go in
the backyard what is going on why do we
you know so I just had to so we could
make it to 26.
incredible though it was such a what a
beautiful thing to do for someone like
is he up the ante like are you planning
for the what are y'all doing for the
next time the ante for him the next one
for me is he more the planner in that
sense he's more the planner I'm not
really good at that either like for it's
funny I'm good at doing that for other
people but not like when the event is
about me I feel like because we always
always Events maybe it's because I'm too
Frugal
oh I I I don't have about their
chandeliers right I know what I did see
the chandelier candles I was like I was
like dang but I'm not matches
that's amazing and you've lasted 25
years you're still doing that's amazing
all right
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]